talk to me about tags because you i
don't even what's your tag
goddammit dupree okay god damn it
dupreeh
i know his sorry jane yeah
but like the tag [ __ ] is so important
and like i feel like there was a lot of
producers hit boys one of them i had a
conversation with him or he was like man
for the forever i would never use with
tag
and
meanwhile you know some of my peers
would be [ __ ]
so brandable because their tag was so
you know and so now hit boys got a
[ __ ] tag on there he's got like three
different ones he uses but like it's so
important how important is like the tag
for a producer because i do feel like
there are there were there's a lot of
producers who don't use tag still but
like for like branding and just for like
recognition like if someone says like
you're janari and if they've heard a
certain they're like oh yeah [ __ ] i know
your [ __ ] you know what i mean like how
important is the tag especially in the
in the beginning it's like detrimental
because that's i mean that's
that's you that's your stamp that's your
name you know like that's how people can
you know like
i never seen you i never heard you but
you know i heard that tag you know so
it's important to have a tag and and to
have a catchy one at that you know i'm
saying like
i think it's very important though in
the in the beginning for sure these
[ __ ] gummies are strong as [ __ ]
how many did you did you just eat one
yeah two oh you had two it's like
another one
oh you had three of them yeah that's not
a micro dose anymore
look at the back of that back bud
hey these balls wow sweet as a [ __ ]
you're currently uh in the touch of
reality phase if you look at the back of
the tops back
this is touch of reality
which one
oh you guys are in the morning micro
dose phase
you guys had one definitely somewhere
perfect i'm not here
i'm definitely feeling realistic right
now oh [ __ ] y'all understand i feel good
though
but
yeah hey look
oh my god
hey no look when he was sending tags i
wanted to say something about producers
with the tags right yeah a lot of [ __ ]
don't even worry about the beat and just
a tag be more important than the beat
like yeah [ __ ] behind me that's the
brandon he's crappy ass beats that is
true but i think like
with that i don't really want to speak
for them but like just with like a lot
of good producers like i think that's
the last thing i watch [ __ ]
just put so much emphasis on the tag
instead of making sure that a [ __ ]
could rap on this beat and make a dope
song
like a lot of producers this me speaking
from an artist standpoint
a lot of producers or beat makers they
make beats that's just a groove
you know what i'm saying it's a banging
ass beat but it's like damn [ __ ] where
i rap at you know what i'm saying all
right so it's like it's just like a
special art to having some [ __ ] that
that knock
and somewhere where you could rap at
that's why i think a lot of like these
simple beats that [ __ ] [ __ ] on they go
because it's somewhere for the artist to
rap on it's simple you're getting busy
and then go you know what i mean a lot
of people do great music but it's like
the cohesiveness of the vocals and then